THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES.
BELL.
GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD.
CAPPIELLO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THERE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
OUR TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
WIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MORNING.
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
THE RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
BY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
AND RESIDENT EVIL SPEND.
A QUORUM IS IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
REVEREND DR GEORGIA PRESCOTT.
CENTER FOR SPIRITUAL AWARENESS
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WE WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG.
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
LET US TAKE A MOMENT TO ANCHOR
OUR CONSCIOUSNESS IN THE HIGHER
POWER.
BY MANY NAMES.
I PRAY TODAY THAT EACH SENATOR
HERE THIS MORNING HAS THE POWER
TO BE GENTLE.
THE STRENGTH TO BE FORGIVING.
THE PATIENTS TO BE UNDERSTANDING
AND THE ENDURANCE TO ACCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HOLDING ON TO
WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS RIGHT.
MAY THEY PUT THEIR TRUST IN THE
POWER OF GOOD TO OVERCOME EVIL.
AND THE POWER OF LOVE TO
OVERCOME HATE.
HELP THEM TO DEVOTE THEIR ENERGY
TO THE TASK OF BEING SMART.
TOUGH COMPASSIONATE LEADERS
PRAYING ALWAYS FOR THE
INSPIRATION TO CREATE A
GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS PROSPERS CLIMATE CARING
AND PROJECTS ALL CITIZENS
REGARDLESS OF COLOR.
BIRTH PLACE OR LIFESTYLE
[inaudible]
A MAN.
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
[inaudible]
WHICH STANDS [inaudible]
ASIAN.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
PRIVILEGE PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
SENATOR ACTIONS.
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU I RISE COLLEAGUES TO
INTRODUCE EXECUTIVE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION.
WHO ARE IN THE GALLERY WITH US
TODAY THEY'RE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS FROM VARIOUS PARTS OF OUR
STATE INCLUDING OF COURSE FOR MY
DISTRICT?
I WANT TO WELCOME MY CONSTITUENT
IAN CAMPBELL WITH DAVEY TREE
CARE BUT I WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR BEING HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEIR POLICY ISSUES.
AND THEIR STATE CAPITOL TODAY
COLLEAGUES CAN YOU JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM [inaudible]
I THANK YOU FOR JOINING US IN
THE SENATE TODAY.
CONTINUING WITH PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR [inaudible]
SENATOR BELL.
GOOD MORNING -- MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
RECOGNIZE APRIL -- TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IS THE CALIFORNIA
FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE PROGRAM ON
THIS PROGRAM WAS FOUNDED.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND FOCUSES
ON YOUTH DEVELOPMENT WITH THE
MISSION OF BUILDING PARTNERSHIPS
FOR POSITIVE AND HEALTH.
HEALTHY YOUTH IN DEVELOPMENT THE
USE SERVICE ACTIVE LEADERS AND
RESOURCES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THEY WERE COLLECTIVELY.
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO REDUCE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU. TO
ACCESS ALCOHOL. TO ADDRESS A
TRAGIC NUMBERS OF DEATHS AND
INJURIES CAUSED BY UNDER AGE
DRINKING AND DRIVING.
A FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE OPERATES IN
FIFTY THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
WITH THE PART WITH PARTICIPATION.
IN MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
CHAPTERS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
ADULT ALLIES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE A FEW OF
THE ADMIRAL FRIDAY NIGHT LIKE
USE.
HEAR.
FROM ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL.
DAN PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING FRIDAY NIGHT.
LIFE AND ALL THE YOU.
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM
SPREADING POSITIVE INFLUENCE AND
MOTIVATING HEALTHY LIFE CHOICES
AMONG YOUR PEERS PLEASE
PARTICIPATE IN YOUR OWN DISTRICT
PROGRAM FOR FRIDAY NIGHT LIFE
THANK YOU
-- YEAH
[inaudible]
NOW.
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE ROOSEVELT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO ARE
HERE TODAY AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK.
MOVING ON TO MESSAGES MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR THEY WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT THE WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR APRIL
FIRST THROUGH THE FOURTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK [inaudible]
CENTER WILK.
PRESIDENT SORRY FOR THE DELAY I
REQUEST TO MOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE SR TWENTY EIGHT TO
THE AN ACTIVE FILE.
THE DESK WILL NOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTY FOUR WITH THE
MOMENTS IN A BILL FOR SEVENTY
FIVE WITH THE MEMBERS THIRTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
SIXTEEN WITH THE MEMONS.
IN ABOUT FOUR NINETY FIVE SIX
FORTY FIVE IN READING FILE WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING.
ITEM NUMBER. FOURTEEN SENATOR
HILL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR HILL RELATIVE TO THE NO
BEFORE YOU FLY EDUCATIONAL
CAMPAIGN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SR
TWENTY ONE RECOGNIZES NO BEFORE
YOU FLY A CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE
PROSPECTIVE USERS ABOUT THE SAFE
AND RESPONSIBLE OPERATION OF
UNMANNED AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS.
ALSO KNOWN AS DRONES THE
CAMPAIGN WAS CREATED BY THE
ACADEMY OF MODEL AERONAUTICS AND
THE ASSOCIATION FOR UNMANNED
VEHICLE SYSTEMS INTERNATIONAL.
AND LAUNCHED IN DECEMBER TWENTY
FOURTEEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FEDERAL AVIATION ADMINISTRATION
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ASSOCIATIONS ORGANIZATIONS AND
BUSINESSES FROM THE MANNED AND
UNMANNED.
AVIATION COMMUNITY SUPPORT THE
CAMPAIGN FOR CALIFORNIANS THAN
EVER ARE FLYING DRONES FOR
BUSINESS AND RECREATIONAL LIKE
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY DO
SO SAFELY.
KNOW BEFORE YOU FLY PROVIDES
DRONE USERS WITH THE INFORMATION
AND GUIDANCE THEY NEED TO FLY
SAFELY AND RESPONSIBLY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MEMBERS THANK YOU MATT.
IS THERE ANY COMMENT OR
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SENATOR OF
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM CEMETERY
CAM MATTEO. FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER FORWARD AS MOST
OF YOU.
MAY KNOW I HAVE WORKED FOR
SEVERAL YEARS TOWARD ENSURING
THE DRONE USING CALIFORNIA IS
DONE SAFELY AND RESPONSIBLY.
EFFECTIVE SAFETY CAMPAIGNS LIKE
NO BEFORE YOU FLY OR PART OF
THAT SOLUTION.
BUT SAFETY CAMPAIGN TO ALONE ARE
NOT THE ANSWER.
THE LACK OF CLEAR RULES
GOVERNING THE USE OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES TO
UNDERMINE PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND HARM CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
RESOURCES THE LACK OF REGULATION
ON DRONE NEWS HAS LED TO
DISPUTES.
BETWEEN NEIGHBORS CONCERNING
THEIR BELIEF IN THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE INVASION OF THEIR
PRIVACY.
THAT HAS HAD IMPACTS ON WILDLIFE
NEAR COLLISIONS WITH AIRPLANES
AND HELICOPTERS INTERFERENCE
WITH FIREFIGHTERS EFFORTS AND
ACCIDENTS INJURING INNOCENT
BYSTANDERS.
THIS LACK OF REGULATION HAS
CREATED LITERALLY A
TECHNOLOGICAL WHILE WEST.
WELL I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY AND THANK THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN MATTEO FOR
RAISING THE ISSUE IN BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
I DO FEEL IT NECESSARY TO MAKE
IT CLEAR.
THAT SAFETY CAMPAIGNS AND BEST
PRACTICES CANNOT THIS PLACE THE
TRADITIONAL ROLE OF STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO RESTRICT
DRONE USE WHEN NECESSARY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF
PRIVACY THAT WE ALL SHARE WITH
THAT.
I SUPPORT THIS MEASURE URGENT
AYE VOTE BUT AGAIN CAUTION US
THAT THERE IS STILL MUCH MORE TO
BE DONE.
THERE ANY COM OTHER COMMENTS OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
JOHN [inaudible]
SENATOR JONES [inaudible]
SAYING.
NINE SENATOR HILL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BILL
KAULITZ THANK YOU.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
HI BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
HI.
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
HI DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
HI.
GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE HER TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON.
HI JONES.
BY LEYVA.
I AM A BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
CASSIE.
I WIENER.
HI WILL.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENTEES GLAZER [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
THE STOP.
THE ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
CENTER MCGUIRE.
YEAH ACTUALLY I THINK YOU WILL
PASS ON FILE [inaudible]
OKAY -- YES A SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RAD
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR REQUIRE
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA WINES AND
DOWN TO EARTH MONTH.
I APOLOGIZE BETTER PRESENT WE'RE
GONNA PASS ON FILE AT THE SECTOR
DID A WONDERFUL READ.
JACK THANK YOU.
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
SIXTEEN SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR DODD AND THAT CLING TO
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES.
MADAM RESIDENT MEMBERS SB TWO
THIRTY TWO CONFORMS CALIFORNIA
LAW TO THE TOXICS IN PACKAGING
CLEARINGHOUSE.
T. PCH MODEL LAW WHICH SETS TWO
HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION AS THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE AMOUNT OF
HEAVY METALS THEY CAN BE USED IN
RECYCLED PACKAGING.
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED ITS OWN TOXIC
PACKAGING A PREVENTION ACT IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE JUST LIKE
NINETEEN OTHER STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
GLASS BOTTLES CONTAIN TRACE
AMOUNTS TO LEAD SINCE COLLEGE.
WHICH IS SOURCE FOR MANY TYPES
OF GLASS PRODUCTS THAT COME FROM
AROUND.
MANY MANY COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD IS COSTLY RECYCLED TO MEET
THE TWO HUNDRED PER MILLION
STANDARD GLASS MANUFACTURERS
MUST REDUCE THE PERCENTAGE OF
RECYCLED CALL IT IN THE GLASS
MANUFACTURING.
PROCESS THE LET'S CALL IT USED
IN THE GLASS MANUFACTURING
PROCESS MEANS MORE USE GLASS
WILL STAY IN THE WAY STREAMING
BE LAND FILLED.
RELEASE OF MORE GREENHOUSE GASES
UNLESS RECYCLED CONTENT
PACKAGING THIS IS CONTRARY TO
STATE LAW AND POLICIES.
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES DEMONSTRATE
THAT THE TWO HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION STANDARD FOR GLASS
PACKAGING IS NOT IN ANY WAY
HARMFUL AND THAT IS WHY THE
MODEL CODE SETS THAT.
AS THE MAXIMUM CONTENT STANDARD
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS ARE.
MEMBERS ARE THERE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
THING THEN.
THIS ITEM IS -- IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS.
CONSENT.
IT ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. THIRTY SEVEN ICE ZERO
NOTE.
MEASURE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN WE'RE GONNA PASS ON
FILE ON THAT WHEN [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG [inaudible]
OKAY.
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN SENATOR DR SO
[inaudible]
YOU PREPARED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY FIVE A
SENATOR DORADO AND ACTING TO
CITIZENS OF THE STATE.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING SISTERS AND
BROTHERS.
OUR RIGHTS TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON SB.
TWO TWO FIVE THIS BILL WOULD
ENSURE THAT ALL QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
MAY SERVE ON CALIFORNIA STATE
AND LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THROUGH APPOINTMENTS.
SB TWO TWO FIVE REMOVES ON
OBSOLETE CODE SECTION WRITTEN IN
THE EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES. TO
EXCLUDE IMMIGRANTS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN CIVIC LIFE.
THIS BILL WILL NOT CIRCUMVENT
FEDERAL AUTHORITY TO EMPLOY A
DOCUMENT UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
THIS IS NOT A BILL ABOUT
EMPLOYMENT.
THE INTENT OF SB TWO TWO FIVE IS
TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO SERVICE
AND AUTHORIZED ALL QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS TO SERVE ON
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE LOCAL AND
STATE.
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS SO THAT
THEIR PERSPECTIVE AND VOICES ARE
HEARD TO BETTER REFLECT ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO OFFER A HARD
WORKING PEOPLE WITH DIVERSE
EXPERIENCES TALENTS AN ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENTS OF BOYS.
IN THE STATE WHERE THEY LIVE AND
WORK.
AS A LEGAL MATTER THIS BILL WILL
LINE EDITOR HERE ALSO PLEASE.
PLEASE CAN WE GET SOME --
RESPECT FOR SENATOR DORADO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR COMMENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE OF THE FLOOR IF
IF YOU NEED TO SPEAK.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO OFFER HARD
WORKING PEOPLE WITH DIVERSE
EXPERIENCES TALENTS AND ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENTS A VOICE IN THE
STATE WHERE THEY LIVE AND WORK.
AS A LEGAL MATTER THIS BILL WILL
ALIGN THE STATE'S DEFINITION OF
CITIZEN QUOTE UNQUOTE WITH THE
DEFINITION FOUND IN THE
CITIZENSHIP CLAUSE OF THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT.
PUTTING AN END TO ALL LANGUAGE
MEANT TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CHINESE IMMIGRANTS.
COLLEAGUES WITH THAT SAID I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING SB TWO TWO FIVE FORWARD.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR TO LETTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I SUPPORT TWO TWO FIVE BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE IN OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE WORKING EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN OUR PARKS IN OUR SCHOOLS --
GIVING UP THEIR TIME THEY KNOW
THE COMMUNITY FORWARD AND
BACKWARDS AND THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO SERVE AS IS PARK
COMMISSIONERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES SERVE ON VARIOUS
BOARDS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE COMMUNITY
THEY ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THEY ARE PART OF
OUR EVERYDAY LIVES THEY SHOULD
BE HONORED FOR THE THE TIME THEY
GIVE TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND THEY
SHOULD BE GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO WITH THAT MADAM I SUPPORT.
TWO TWO FIVE IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
THING THEN.
YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
A SET UP.
SORRY SISTERS OR BROTHERS I'M SO
USED TO USING THAT TERM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BILL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS [inaudible]
WE'RE JUST [inaudible]
NO.
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI.
HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
MORE LOCK NO NO [inaudible]
WELL.
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I LIKE COUNTY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO.
MORNING.
HI NIELSEN.
VICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE THE
BILL.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
NINETEEN CENTER LEYVA
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LEYVA
RELATIVE TO ORGAN AND TISSUE
DONATION.
THANK YOUMADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I RISE TODAY AS
A PROUD AUTHORED S. C. R. TWENTY
NINE WHICH COMMANDS THE
UNIVERSITY COUNCIL AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
AND THE LIBRARIES THEY REPRESENT
FOR THEIR GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA YOU
SEE LIBRARIANS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO PROVIDE STUDENTS AND FACULTY
WITH COLLECTION MATERIALS
COMPREHENSIVE RESEARCH.
AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
THESE LIBRARIANS.
UPHOLD THE PRESTIGE.
I WAS A STRONG.
ONE I'M NOT DOING TONY LIVE
TODAY [inaudible]
YES.
SO THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN A PASS
ON FILE I APOLOGIZE [inaudible]
YES PLEASE.
OKAY SO WE'LL WE'LL START THAT
OVER AGAIN -- ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN IS I PASS ON FILE.
SO.
ARE WE WILL TAKE UP.
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AT TWENTY OKAY.
SENATOR LEYVA ON THIS ONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY SO MANY YES ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO THE
UNIVERSITY COUNCIL AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
WELL MEMBERS GOOD MORNING AGAIN
I AM STILL HERE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW GREAT THE LIBRARIANS ARE I
WILL NOT TO REPEAT WHAT I'VE
SAID SO FAR.
THESE LIBRARIANS UP HOLD THE
PROCEEDS OF THE UC AS A NATION
LEADING RESEARCH INSTITUTION AND
EMBODY THE PUBLIC MISSION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS EVERY LIBRARIAN DESERVES
A LIVING WAGE AND BENEFITS TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES S. YOU'RE TWENTY NINE
HIGHLIGHTS THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE UC F. T. AND IT'S MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY YOU
SEE LIBRARIANS.
AS WELL AS RECOGNIZES THEIR
EFFORTS TO SECURE ADEQUATE
COMPENSATION AND BENEFITS TO
REFLECT THEIR VALUE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
BY THE ROLL CALL PLEASE
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER HI HI JANE
[inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER HI GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER. FIVE A CASKEY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
JONES.
MORE LOCK AND WE CAN MORRELL
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SO WE ARE. TWENTY FOUR MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY ONE PASS ON FILE MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO SENATOR PAN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY DECENNIAL CENSUS.
THANK YOU -- EVERYONE LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA MATTERS AND EVERYONE
COUNTS.
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS TODAY
RISE TO BRING YOU SR TWENTY
SEVEN WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
U. S. DECENNIAL CENSUS.
AS OF APRIL FIRST JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO WE WERE ONE YEAR OUT
FROM CENSUS DAY TWENTY TWENTY SO
KEEP THAT IN MIND NEXT YEAR
APRIL FIRST.
AFTER WE HAD AN EXCITING PRIMARY
WE HAVE TO GIVE ONE COUNTED.
AND IN ONE YEAR THE US CENSUS
BUREAU BEGAN THE MONUMENTAL TASK
OF COUNTING EVERY SINGLE PERSON
LIVING WITHIN OUR COUNTRY.
AND WE HAVE ONE CHANCE TO GET IT
RIGHT EVERY TEN YEARS.
SR TWENTY SEVEN RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING COMPLETE
COUNT OF EVERY CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE IS A LOT AT STAKE IN
OUR CENSUS COUNTS.
TENS OF BILLIONS OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS ARE BASED ON CENSUS
POPULATION NUMBERS.
THE NUMBER DISTRIBUTION OF A
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS.
ARE DETERMINED BY THE CENSUS ARE
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION WILL BE
USING US CENSUS DATA TO DRAW THE
LINE. FOR OUR FUTURE DISTRICTS.
CENTER STATE IS ALSO USED BY
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS.
AND PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY IN
MY MIND AS A RESEARCHER.
CENSUS DATA BASICALLY IS THE
BASELINE DATA WE USE FOR THE
DECADE. FOR NOT JUST THAT DECADE
BUT FOR ALL TIME SO WHEN SOMEONE
LOOKS BACK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
THIRTY THEY'RE GOING TO USE THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS DATA.
WHICH MEANS THAT ANYONE WHO
ISN'T COUNTED IS ESSENTIALLY
ERASED FROM HISTORY.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
OUR THAT CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY.
IS COUNTED.
WE HAVE A CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY GEOGRAPHICALLY
DIVERSE STATE BUT THAT ALSO
MEANS WE HAVE MANY HARD TO COUNT
POT PEOPLE -- COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE STILL CALIFORNIA HAS
RECOGNIZED THE IN CRITICAL PORTS
AND WE HEAR THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
ALLOCATE A READY HUNDRED MILLION.
AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND
ANOTHER.
THIS PROPOSED FOR ANOTHER FIFTY
FOUR MILLION THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INCLUDE THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. TO BE SURE THAT EVERYONE
GETS COUNTED WE ALSO ARE
BUILDING STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN THE STATE.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND I HOPE AND APPRECIATED THAT
MANY IF YOU YOUR DISTRICT
OFFICES ARE HELPING.
US GET REACH OUT AND BE SURE
EVERYONE IS COUNTED.
SO AGAIN WE HAVE ONE YEAR TO GET
IT RIGHT WE HAVE ONE YEAR TO BE
SURE THAT EVERYONE.
IS COUNTED AND THAT OUR ENTIRE
STATE IS REPRESENTED IN THE
CENSUS HI SPEC WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SR TWENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
IS THEREANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SITTING NINE MEMBERS THIS IS AN
ITEM THAT IS A SUBJECT FOR
UNANIMOUS ROW CALL ARE THERE ANY
OBJECTIONS. THIRTY SIX OUR EYES
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ZERO THE MATTER IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR REQUIRE AN APPLE INTO
CANNABIS IN THE CLEAN THERE'S
THREATS TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND GOOD MORNING MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
WERE PROTECT THOUSANDS OF
CANNABIS FARMERS.
WHO DID THE RIGHT THING IN
APPLIED FOR A STATE LICENSE BUT
THEIR TEMPORARY STATE LICENSE
HAS EXPIRED OR IS ABOUT TO
EXPIRE IN BECAUSE OF THE
INABILITY TO EXTEND THEIR
LICENSE DUE TO EXISTING STATE
LAW?
WILL DROP BACK INTO THE ILLEGAL
BLACK MARKET.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE SIX THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED TEMPORARY STATE
CANNABIS LICENSES IN THE STATE
SYSTEM WITH ALMOST ALL OF
EXPIRING BETWEEN NOW AND JULY.
IN THE MONTH OF APRIL ALONE NEAR
THE FOUR THOUSAND FOUR THOUSAND
TEMPORARY GROWING LICENSES
ISSUED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG ARE SET
TO EXPIRE ONE THOUSAND RD
EXPIRED.
THIS PAST MONTH.
THIS IS THE WORST WAY TO
TRANSITION A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR AGRICULTURE MARKET WHICH
EMPLOYS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT LEGAL
LICENSES THERE ISN'T A LEGAL
REGULATED MARKET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE UNDER CURRENT LAW HAS
NO ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO EXTEND
A TEMPORARY LICENSE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THERE IS SET TO EXPIRE.
AS A TEMPORARY LICENSES COME DO
IT DISTINCT CAN APPROVE OR DENY
AN ANNUAL LICENSE PRIOR THE
TEMPORARY LICENSE EXPIRING THE
LICENSE FARMER WILL NO LONGER BE
OPERATING LEGALLY.
SB KICK BACK INTO THE BLACK
MARKET.
SB SIXTY SEVEN ALLOWS CDFA TO
EXTEND TEMPORARY LICENSES HELD
BY LICENSEES WHILE THEY'RE IN
YOUR APPLICATION IS BEING
PROCESS.
THROUGH SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH OF
THIS YEAR THEY CREATE A SHORT
TERM BRIDGE IN SOLUTION TO AVOID
AN IMPENDING CRISIS AND SETS UP
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS THIS YEAR
ABOUT HOW TO CREATE.
A LONG TERM PATHWAY TO CREATING
A THRIVING MARKET PLAYS FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR -- BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS FOR ALL OF HIS WORK
ON THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IN
COMMITTEE THE MORE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
VERY GOOD IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
THING NINE YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
HI DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI LABOR [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
HI NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY [inaudible]
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS FOR
ON THE URGENCY BECAUSE FIVE
THIRTY TO NOTE.
FOR KNOWS FOR HER ON THE BILL
THE MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR UMBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWO BY
SENATOR UMBERG RELATIVE TO THE
PRESIDENT'S NATIONAL EMERGENCY
DECLARATION.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES -- FIRST OF LET ME
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA IN CALLING FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE IN
THEIR IMPROVEMENT ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS.
NOT ABOUT IT IS NOT ABOUT THE
WALL PER SE I REALIZE THAT THERE
ARE SOME VERY STRONG FEELINGS.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THAT ISSUE.
AND IT'S REALLY NOT ABOUT THE
NATIONAL DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY -- THE PROPRIETY OF
THAT IS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
BE DEBATED FOR MANY MANY YEARS
TO COME.
THIS IS ABOUT SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL CAN AGREE UPON.
WE ALL CAN AGREE THAT THERE'S AN
EPIDEMIC.
IN THE UNITED STATES CONCERNING
OPIOIDS THEIR ABUSE.
AND THE CONSEQUENCES BEAR OF WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS EXPERTS.
PUT TOGETHER A NATIONAL DRUG
CONTROL POLICY THIS IS DATED
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN IT IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S EXPERTS BELIEVE IS
THE WAY TO ADDRESS.
DRUGS IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S THE PRESIDENT'S VIEW AND IS
EXPERTS AS TO THE WAY TO DEAL
WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS
[inaudible]
NO WHERE.
IN THIS STRATEGY NO WHERE IN THE
PRESENT STRATEGY.
DOES IT MENTION [inaudible]
A WALL.
WHAT DOES THE DOES TALK ABOUT IT
TALKS ABOUT FENNEL AND IT TALKS
ABOUT HEALTH FENNEL IS KILLING?
TENS OF THOUSANDS.
OF OUR CHILDREN OUR BROTHERS OR
SISTERS OR WIVES OR HUSBANDS --
THIS RESOLUTION IS ABOUT.
WHAT THE DIVERSION OF FUNDS DOES
TO CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIANS?
THIS RESOLUTION IS ABOUT.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
NOT WE THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
DIVERT FUNDS FROM WHAT HE SAYS
IS OUR NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL.
POLICY AND STRATEGY. TO ANOTHER
PURPOSE.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT IT'S GOING TO
DO TO CALIFORNIA AND WHAT IT'S
GONNA DO TO CALIFORNIANS IN
TERMS OF MILITARY CONSTRUCTION.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
NECESSARY.
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
GOING TO BE AFFECTED.
BY THIS DIVERSION OF FUNDS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE NAVY SEAL RESERVE
TRAINING FACILITY IN SAN DIEGO.
IN MY OWN DISTRICT THE SEAL
BEACH WEAPONS STATION.
IN OUR OWN DISTRICT NEARBY
DISTRICT NEARBY IS THE HANGER
TRAVIS TRAVIS AIR FORCE BASE
[inaudible]
MOST IMPORTANTLY [inaudible]
ARE THE QUARTERS FOR OUR MEN AND
WOMEN [inaudible]
THAT ARE.
DILAPIDATED HAVE LED INFESTATION.
ALL THESE IMPORTANCE ALL THESE
IMPORTANT PROJECTS AND USES.
ARE GOING TO BE EITHER DELAYED
OR PERHAPS NEVER COMPLETED
BECAUSE THE MONEY IS GOING TO BE
DIVERTED TO ANOTHER PURPOSE.
SO IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT THE WALL
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT YOU MAY
THINK ABOUT THIS NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
WE CAN AGREE THAT THIS DIVERSION
OF FUNDS IS GOING TO BE HARMFUL
TO CALIFORNIAN CALIFORNIANS.
AND I THINK WE CAN AGREE ALL OF
US THAT WE SHOULD SEND A VERY
STRONG MESSAGE.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE
THAT THIS DIVERSION OF FUNDS IS
ANTITHETICAL TO OUR HEALTH AND
WELFARE WELL BEING ECONOMIC AND
OTHERWISE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU BENCHER.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
CENTER WEST OF RIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SJ ARE.
TO LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THIS
WALL IS UNNECESSARY AND A
COMPLETE.
WASTE OF MONEY.
MAKING AN ARGUMENT THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO BUILD A WALL A WALL
UNDER A TWO HUNDRED MILE WALL ON
A TWO THOUSAND MILE BORDER.
DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE SENSE TO ME
I DON'T KNOW TO WHO.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
BUT THAT IF YOU DO THE MATH THAT
LEAVES A THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
MILES [inaudible]
OF WATER WITHOUT WALL WHAT
HAPPENS THERE.
BUT YOU KNOW. ONE OF THE THINGS
THE PRESIDENT SAID IS THAT A
WALL.
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
TESTED IN HISTORY WELL.
EVERY SINGLE WALL.
THE GREAT WALL OF CHINA.
THE GREAT OF THE THE WALL OF
JERUSALEM EVERY WALL.
THAT IS EVER PROTECTED ANYTHING
HAS ALWAYS [inaudible]
FALLEN.
AND EVERY WALL THAT THAT HAS
FALLEN IN HISTORY.
WAS NOT ONLY PENETRATED BUT IT
WAS PENETRATED THROUGH.
RIGOROUS DEFENSES OF PEOPLE THAT
WERE DEFENDING THOSE WALLS WITH
WITH CANNONS AND WEAPONS AND AN
AND HUMAN POWER.
THIS WALL WILL NOT HAVE THAT IT
WILL BE JUST A BLANK.
WALL IT WOULD BE A WALL THAT
ANYBODY COULD SCALAR DIG UNDER
CUT THROUGH.
AND AND THIS IS JUST A UP.
THE RESULT OF AN OF ABSURD PROP.
UP PROMISE.
THE PRESIDENT MADE THAT THE
CONGRESS DID NOT HAVE THE
COURAGE TO BLOCK.
EVERYONE AGREES THIS IS A ABUSE
OF POWER BUT THE CONGRESS JUST
DID NOT HAVE THE BACKBONE. TO
STAND UP AND DO THEIR JOB AND BE
THE CONGRESS WHICH IS PROBABLY
WHY THEY'RE APPROVAL APPROVAL
RATING HAS GONE DOWN. 215%
[inaudible]
AMONG AMERICANS.
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE DEEPLY HURT
BY THIS ACTION IT'LL HURT.
OUR DEFENSES IT'LL HURT VERY
STRATEGIC.
OF PROJECTS THAT WE WE NEED FOR
OUR NATIONAL DEFENSE.
IT'LL GO BASICALLY INTO A HOLE
IN THE GROUND THAT WILL NOT DO
ANYTHING.
WE NEED TO REDUCE FOR WAIT TIMES
TO HELP INCREASE.
OUR ECONOMY THAT REQUIRES AN
INVESTMENT TO HELP.
MOVE PEOPLE MORE EFFICIENTLY TO
THE BORDER YET THE PRESIDENT'S
IS MAKING A THREAT THAT HE'S
GOING TO CLOSE THE BORDERS WHICH
WILL HURT.
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WHICH WILL
COULD HURT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THIS.
A MONTH THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
FILED A LAWSUIT.
AGAINST THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN THEIR HANDLING OF IMMIGRANTS.
AND AND THEY ARE ALSO STRUGGLING
WITH THE PRESIDENT'S POLICIES
ARE NOT ALWAYS HANDLED
IMMIGRANTS.
RESIDENT IS THREATENING TO CUT
OFF AID TO CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES WHICH ARE ONLY
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM AND BRING
MORE PEOPLE FLOCKING TO OUR
BORDERS.
THIS IS JUST A COMPLETE DISASTER
AND HOW THIS PRESIDENT IS
DEALING [inaudible]
WITH.
THE BORDER WITH OUR NEIGHBORS TO
THE SOUTH WITH OUR FRIENDLY
NEIGHBORS TO THE SOUTH WITH
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST TRADING
PARTNER MEXICO THIS IS HEARD IN
OUR STATE.
WE NEED TO SPEAK UP WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT I WANT TO
COMMEND SENATOR -- BURKE FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD.
FOR FOR SENDING A STRONG MESSAGE
TO WASHINGTON.
AND LETTING THEM KNOW WE SEND A
HUNDRED AND TEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN OUR CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
MONEY TO WASHINGTON AND ONLY GET
ABOUT EIGHTY BILLION BACK IN
SERVICES.
WHAT WERE WERE?
SUBSIDIZING THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY CALIFORNIA IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THIS UNION.
AND WE NEED TO SEND A MESSAGE
TELLING THIS PRESIDENT TELLING
THIS CONGRESS TO STOP HURTING
CALIFORNIA.
YOU HEARD CALIFORNIA YOU HEARD
THE NATION.
AND AND WERE WERE FED UP.
WHAT THESE POLICIES OF THIS
PRESIDENT AND THIS CONGRESS AND
HOW THEY'RE DEALING?
WITH OUR OUR TRADING PARTNERS
WITH.
OUR OTHER PEOPLE OF OUR OWN
COMMUNITY.
WITH OF OUR TOURISM INDUSTRY
WITH.
OUR ENTIRE US SECURITY OF OUR
NATION WERE FED UP.
SO WE NEED TO SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE. FOR THIS ADMINISTRATION
TO START STUDYING SOMETHING
START READING SOMETHING START
LEARNING ABOUT SOMETHING BUT
BEFORE THEY START MAKING.
VERY DESTRUCTIVE PAULA BUT IN.
VERY DESTRUCTIVE POLICIES INTO
PLACE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS DR.
TO THE CLEARING THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY IS NOT.
INCONSEQUENTIAL.
PAST PRESIDENTS HAVE DECLARED
NATIONAL EMERGENCY THAT WERE
BASED ON FACTS AN ACTUAL
EMERGENCIES BUT MOST OF THEM
DEALT WITH FOREIGN CRISES IN
TAKING ACTIONS AGAINST NATIONAL
ADVERSARIES.
NOT RE DIRECT THE MONEY WITHOUT
CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL.
ONLY IN TWO OTHER INSTANCES HAVE
EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS BEEN USED
TO SPEND MONEY WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL ONCE BY
GEORGE BUSH SENIOR IN NINETEEN
NINETY DURING THE PERSIAN GULF
WAR.
AND THE OTHER BY GEORGE W. BUSH
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE AFTER THE
NINE ONE ONE ATTACKS.
THE GOAL FOR THE NINE ONE ONE
ATTACKS REQUIRE A MUCH DIFFERENT
ACTION OF URGENCY BY OUR
GOVERNMENT.
THEN THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AT
OUR BORDER.
THE FACTS DO NOT SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ARGUMENT
AGAINST THE DANGERS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THEY SIMPLY DO
NOT.
THE DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY
DIVERTED CRITICAL FUNDS AWAY
FROM MILITARY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT HERE IN OUR VERY OWN
STATE.
I AM CLEAR THAT WHAT WE DECIDE
TO FUND IS A STATEMENT OF WHAT
WE VALUE.
THIS RESOLUTION DECLARES OUR
VALUES AS A STATE AND STANDS UP
FOR THE SEPARATION OF POWERS
OUTLINED IN OUR US CONSTITUTION
AGAIN I STAND THE STRONG SUPPORT
OF FDR [inaudible]
TO SENATOR BELL.
ABOUT PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION WHEN.
WHEN WE -- HAD -- THE
DISCUSSIONS SO ON SB ONE THE
TRANSPORTATION MEASURE -- SIR
WELL SO ARE CENTER FROM SAN
DIEGO EXCUSE ME -- HAD -- MUCH
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT -- TO THE
BORDER CROSSINGS IN THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA.
OF NEEDED -- TO HELP FINANCE THE
BORDER CROSSINGS -- ALL ALONG
THE BORDER AND WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN [inaudible]
PUTTING -- FUNDS.
INTO THE OUT.
ALL ALONG THERE ARE THEN IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT DRUG INTERDICTION AND THOSE
KINDS OF PROGRAM THE BORDER
CROSSINGS AND THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THE IMPROVEMENT OF THOSE BORDER
CROSSINGS.
NOT ONLY HELPS TRADE WITH MEXICO
BUT ALSO HELPS.
WHERE IT'S -- THE STOPPING OF
DRUGS COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
BORDER WALL ACTUALLY DOES
NOTHING TO DO THAT.
SO I TOTALLY SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION THE MONEY SHOULD BE
SPARED.
ON UPGRADING OUR AGING DEFENSE
BILLS BILL TERRY INFRASTRUCTURE --
THE MONEY SHOULD -- COME BACK TO
CALIFORNIA -- THE NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT IS BEEN TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL -- PROJECT -- WE
SHOULD HAVE A NATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE -- PLAN. TO
UPGRADE THE AGING --
INFRASTRUCTURE ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES AS THE FALLING
APART BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS INCREASED --
FUNDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE OVER
THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SO THERE'S OTHER PRIORITIES
OTHER THAN BUILDING A WALL.
THAT WOULD HELP THE PEOPLE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AND THOSE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THOSE
PROJECTS IN THOSE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS.
RATHER THAN -- SOME MEANINGLESS
SO -- POLITICAL CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT -- I WOULD COMPARE -- TO
SIMPLY BUILDING -- A PYRAMID OR
A MONUMENT -- TO SOMEBODY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT IS IS
REALLY -- SOME KIND OF MONUMENT
TO SOMEBODY AS OPPOSED TO
SOMETHING THAT HELPS -- THE
PEOPLE OF THE UNITED STATES LOW --
LET'S BE -- LET'S BE AWARE OF
WHAT THIS REALLY -- BECAUSE
THERE'S OTHER NEEDS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
AND WE HAVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THOSE OTHER NEEDS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
NEEDS THOSE BORDER CROSSINGS WE
NEED HAVE THOSE FUNDED FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
COME UP WITH SOME PLANS TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE BEFORE WE FUND
THIS THIS PROJECT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
THING MAN SENATOR UMBERG YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
I GET IT THERE ARE HARD FEELINGS
ABOUT.
THE WALL.
BUT AGAIN WE CAN ALL AGREE.
THAT WE SHOULD SEND A MESSAGE TO
WASHINGTON MEASURE THE PRESIDENT
MISTER PRESIDENT DO NOT
CONTRAVENE.
YOUR OWN ADMINISTRATION AS TO
HOW TO BEST DEAL WITH THE
FEDERAL CRISIS MISTER PRESIDENT
DO NOT CONTRAVENE THE EXPERTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FENCES TO HOW
BEST TO DEAL WITH OUR NATIONAL
DEFENSE.
MISTER PRESIDENT DO NOT PUNISH
CALIFORNIA MISTER PRESIDENT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE LARGEST
PORTION OF THE FUNDS THAT YOU'RE
SEEKING TO DIVERT.
WOULD COME THE CALIFORNIA MISTER
PRESIDENT DON'T DO THAT TO US.
I ORIGINAL VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL.
I WERE JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I GOT A YELLOW HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
BY DORADO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH
[inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WISH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
HI MY COUNTY I WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
THE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
ABSENTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WILK.
THE ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS KNOWS
SEVEN THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR GALGIANI.
WE'RE GONNA PASS ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY SIX CENTER LEYVA.
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR ALAN.
WILL PASS ON FILE ON THAT ITEM
AS WELL.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR RUBIO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY FIVE US AND RUBIO
RELATIVE TO STAY SCIENTISTS DAY.
A PASS ON FILE.
ON THAT ITEM.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWENTY NINE SENATOR WILK.
WE'VE MOVED BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE MOVE THAT TO
THE INACTIVE FILE.
SO THAT -- CONCLUDES OUR SENATE
THIRD READING.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE ASSEMBLY
STE PLEASE READ MISTER SECRETARY.
OH OKAY IT'S ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
WHICH IS -- SET.
WILL BE IT'S GOING TO BE PERCENT
OF HER SENATOR MCGUIRE PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND THAT
GOING TO TAXATION AND CUTTING
THEIR THROUGHOUT THE TAKE BACK
TO ME THE SENATOR MCGUIRE HEY
GOOD MORNING MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS OF
PLEASE TODAY TO BRING FORWARD AB.
ONE FORTY SEVEN THIS IS BEEN A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AUTUMN BURKE IS DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB.
STATE TREASURER FIONA MA IN
MYSELF ALONG WITH THE GOOD
MEMBERS OF GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THE U. S. SUPREME COURT'S WAY
FAIR DECISION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A WELL THOUGHT OUT AND
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH THE WAY
FAIR DECISION IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT U. S. SUPREME COURT
DECISIONS IN DECADES.
BECAUSE IT REMOVES THE
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE ONLINE AN
OUT OF STATE BUSINESSES HAVE HAD.
THEY DID NOT COLLECT SALES TAX
IN A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE OVER
BRICK AND MORTAR CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS WHO HAVE ALWAYS
COLLECTED TAXES.
THIS INEQUITY CAN GIVE A BIG ED
FROM SEVEN POINT 25% TO MORE
THAN 10% DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU
LIVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS ADVANTAGE GOES TO ADD TO
SAY COMPANIES AN ONLINE
RETAILERS. THIRTY THREE STATES
RATHER PRESIDENT ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED THE COURT'S DECISION
AND EVERY OTHER STATE WITH THE
SALES TAX IS EXPECTED TO FOLLOW
SUIT.
AB ONE FORTY SEVEN DOES THIS FOR
THE GOLDEN STATE.
THE MEASURE WILL INCREASE STATE
AND LOCAL REVENUES BY AN
ESTIMATED FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
AND MANY OF THESE LOCAL REVENUES
ARE DEDICATED TO LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL.
THE BILL STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN ALL STAKEHOLDERS
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ONLINE
pAND MANY OTHERS.
IT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM.
LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SENATOR SKINNER.
HI THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY BUT I THOUGHT IT
WAS WORTH IT -- TO MAY I BRING
UP SOME POINTS SO THE LAW THAT
ENABLED CALIFORNIA. TO IN EFFECT
REQUIRE INTERNET RETAILERS TO
COLLECT SALES TAX WHICH THEY
WERE.
NOT.
REQUIRED TECHNICALLY TO DO --
PRIOR TO TWENTY ELEVEN SO
CALIFORNIA'S SALES TAX LAW WAS
BASED ON THAT YOU HAD TO HAVE A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA
BUT AS INTERNET SALES GREW.
AND WE OBVIOUSLY SAW SOME
COMPANIES BASICALLY DESIGN THEIR
ENTIRE BUSINESS MODEL TO AVOID
HAVING TO COLLECT SALES TAX.
THE STATE'S -- COLLECTION OF
SALES TAX BEGAN TO DROP -- AND
YET EACH OF US AS INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYERS WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE IF WE BOUGHT SOMETHING
EITHER OUT OF STATE FOR ON LINE.
THAT HAD A SALES TAX BUT WE
DIDN'T PAY IT DIRECTLY THEN WE
WERE SUPPOSED TO PAY IT IS USE
TAX NOW WHO'S IT HARDER TO
COLLECT FROM THE FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO MIGHT YOU KNOW.
INDIVIDUALLY PURCHASED SOMETHING
OR SOME HANDFUL AND WHEN I SEE
HIM FOR ME IT'S MORE THAN A
HANDFUL BUT IT'S LESS THAN FORTY
MILLION CERTAINLY RETAILERS.
SO IN TWENTY ELEVEN WE PASSED
THE BILL THAT CREATED WHAT'S
CALLED THE ALARM ON LONG ARM
NEXUS WHICH MEANT WELL ANYWAY.
WE'LL WE'LL LEAVE THAT
EXPLANATION NOW.
AT THAT POINT WE SET THE
THRESHOLD AT ONE MILLION SO IN
OTHER WORDS.
ONLY.
INTERNET SELLERS WITH SALES OF A
MILLION OR ABOVE HAD TO COLLECT
THAT SALES TAX INTERNET OVER THE
STATE NO THAT WAS A COMPROMISE.
THE OTHER STATES THAT HAD LAWS
NEW YORK STATE FOR EXAMPLE IN
OTHERS NONE OF THEM HAD IT BELOW
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY K..
SO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY K. WAS THE
NORMAL THRESHOLD BUT WE SET IT
AT A MILLION.
NOW WE ARE TAKING UP THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE COURT RULED IN THE
WAY FAIRS CASE THAT.
HEY.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED THE LONG ARM
NEXUS EVERY SELLER OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ABOVE.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COLLECT THE
SALES TAX IN STATE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO REMOTE IT.
OR GET IT.
SO I RAISE THAT BECAUSE THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY WHILE A
GREAT IMPROVEMENT OVER WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE.
WHICH IS CURRENTLY WE HAVE THE
ONE MILLION SO THIS BRINGS IT TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND STORE
CAPTURE SOME MORE.
IT STILL DOES NOT CAPTURE ALL
INTERNET SALES NOW THE ARGUMENT
THAT SOME WOULD GIVE IS THAT
WELL THAT GAP BETWEEN SAY
500-100-0100 THOUSAND IS NOT
THAT MANY SELLERS AND IT'S A LOT
OF HASSLE TO GO AFTER THOSE
PEOPLE TO COLLECT THAT SALES TAX.
WELL WHAT'S MORE OF A HASSLE
GOING AFTER EACH OF US
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS THE
COLLECTOR USE TAX OR THOSE
SELLERS OVER A HUNDRED KA NOW
WHAT I WOULD ALSO NOTE.
IS.
EVERY BRICK AND MORTAR BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF
THEIR SIZE EVEN IF THEIR SALES
ARE ONLY FIVE KA YEAR OR TEN K.
YEAR MUST COLLECT SALES TAX.
SO THIS OSTENSIBLY BEING NICE TO
SMALL BUSINESS IS ONLY BEING
NICE TO SMALL BUSINESSES OUT OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WE ARE ALLOWING BUSINESSES
OUT OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
SALES BETWEEN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND NOT TO
HAVE TO COLLECT OUR SALES TAX SO
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE MAY WANT
TO CORRECT IN THE FUTURE.
BUT I SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
BECAUSE IT IS AN IMPROVEMENT AND
IT DOES ALLOW US TO COLLECT SOME
TAX STARTING NOW IN APRIL BUT I
HOPE THAT WE WOULD ADDRESS IT
AND DO WHAT THE WAY FAIR
DECISION WOULD ALLOW US.
TO IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
THING.
NINE CENTER MCGUIRE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT IWANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY.
SHE TOOK THIS ISSUE ON EARLY ON
IN HAS BEEN A CHAMPION HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND SHE NEEDS TO
BE COMMENDED.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR HER DEEP DIVE
IN WHAT IS ONE OF THE MORE
COMPLICATED SUBJECTS THAT WILL
BE IN FRONT OF US -- IN HERE'S
WHAT I'LL SAY ON THAT ISSUE.
NUMBER ONE THIS IS THE SAME
THRESHOLD THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
PRESENTED LAST YEAR TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE -- IN WAS
ULTIMATELY NOT MOVED ON IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BY
INCREASING THE DISTRICT TAX
THRESHOLD TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IT NEARS THE
SAME THRESHOLD FOR STATE TAX
PURPOSES.
WHICH REDUCES THE BURDEN ON THE
LOCAL SIDE FOR IN STATE FIRMS.
AND ALL INDEED HERE.
I WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
AGAIN THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BURKE.
TREASURE Mà INTO THE INCREDIBLE
STAFF WITH MR NOW IN MISTER RUFF
UP FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADVANCING THIS BILL
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ON THIS.
SUPREME COURT SETTLEMENT.
VERY GOOD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN
[inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PORCHES.
BY BRADFORD BY CARRIER HI I
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK BY MORALE
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I LIKE OWSKI.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN HI. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO.
ZERO ON ON ON THE URGENCY AND
FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
BILL.
THE BILL PASSES.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FOR TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR AND A SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS THERE ANY MEMBER THAT WOULD
LIKE AN ITEM REMOVED FROM EITHER
OF THOSE TWO CALENDARS.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE CONSENT
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME -- I'M SORRY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THEM.
THE BILL EXCEPT AT
1-641-406-1407 314-379-38380 ONE
SENATE BILL.
THREE OH EIGHT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO FORTY
THREE FORTY FIVE AND ASSEMBLY
CARESS LUCIEN.
FORTY SIX OKAY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON I ON
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
THIRTY SEVEN ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
BY BILL.
HI PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
BY COMING HERE -- HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HAIDAR ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
BY WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE ABA CASKEY.
AYE WIENER.
HI WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT ONE MORE
TIME TO WILL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
NIELSEN
.
IT'S INTERESTING.
YOU WALK AWAY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS LEYVA.
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ICE SIX NO ZEROS THE KIDS.
THE CONSENT CALENDARS -- ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR RIGHT HUSKY [inaudible]
THAT.
MADAM PRESIDENT -- BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO WILL BE MEETING ES IN
ROOM -- ONE ONE TWO FIFTEEN
MINUTES UPON GERMAN [inaudible]
SENATOR ROBB.
THINK ABOUT PRESIDENT BUDGET --
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATIONAL WILL YOU EAT MEETING
INROOM THREE ONE NINETY ONE
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER GERMAN
[inaudible]
SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
SAYS THAT IT BUT JUST IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WILL CONVENE AT TEN THIRTY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE THANK
YOU.
SENATOR RUSSELL.
YES THANK YOU US IN THE BUDGET
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR WILL
MEET IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THE SESSION IS OVER [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
YES -- THE BUDGET SUB FIVE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WILL
ROUTE MEET IN ROOM.
ONE THIRTEEN IN MINUTES AFTER
SESSION CONCLUDES.
SEEING NO OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS THE TIME --TO TO
ADDRESS THE ADJOURN IN MEMORIES
[inaudible]
SENATOR GROW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE I'M HONORED TO JOIN IN
THE MEMORY OF AND RECOGNIZE AN
INCREDIBLE LIFE AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF A SMALL TOWN
FARM BOY FROM TULARE COUNTY.
HENRY P. ANDERSON AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWN AS CORKY CORKING HIS
BROTHER DOUG ALWAYS WANTED TO
FOLLOW IN THEIR FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER'S FOOTSTEPS AND
BECOME FARMERS SO THEY DID.
CORGI START STARTED HAULING ON
HATE WITH HIS BROTHER BOB AT
THIRTEEN YEARS OLD LATER HE
STARTED A NURSERY BUSINESS WITH
HIS PH<c.cyan> FRIEND CAN.</c>
AND DAY PATENT A SEVERAL RILEY
VARIETIES OF PISTACHIOS ONE OF
THOSE VARIETIES IS A CALIFORNIA
PER STASHED PISTACHIO WHICH IS
RIGHT WHICH REVOLUTIONIZED THE
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA PISTACHIO
INDUSTRY.
CORKY MOVE HIS BUSINESS TO AN
AREA IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH
DIDN'T HAVE ANY -- PISTACHIO
PRODUCTION AT ALL OR VERY LITTLE
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT HE
WAS COMPLETELY CRAZY HOWEVER
CORKY'S MOVE STARTED TO THE BILL
MEAN PISTACHIO INDUSTRY THAT WE
NOW HAVE IN THIS GREAT
AGRICULTURAL STATE.
CALIFORNIA WAS ON THE BRINK OF
LOSING ITS PISTACHIO INDUSTRY
WHEN A VIRAL SOIL FUNGUS WAS
INTRODUCED TO THE STATE.
AS ALWAYS CORKY WITH HIS
INNOVATION AND SOLUTIONS HE
CREATED A PAT PISTACHIO ROOT
STOCK THAT WAS RESISTANT TO THE
FUNGUS WHICH SINGLE HANDEDLY
SAVE THE ENTIRE PISTACHIO
INDUSTRY.
HE WAS ALSO INSTRUMENTAL IN
ADVANCING I AM IN ADVOCATING FOR
MORE WATER FOR CENTRAL VALLEY
FARMERS AND MUCH AND MUCH OF THE
SOURCE THE SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S PISTACHIO INDUSTRY
CAME.
AND BECAME NUMBER ONE IN THE
WORLD IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
WHEN HE IT WAS ATTRIBUTED TO HIS
BROTHER AND CORKY.
SO EVERYTHING THAT WAS DONE AND
THE PISTACHIO INDUSTRY THAT PUT
THE PISTACHIO INDUSTRY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ON THE MAP CORKY ANDERSON HAD
HIS FINGERS IN.
THIS SMALL TOWN BOY QUICKLY
BECAME ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PISTACHIO FARMERS IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD HIS WORK REACH
FURTHER THAN JUST CALIFORNIA'S
PISTACHIO INDUSTRY HE INVESTED
IN GOLD MINES IN OREGON A WIND
FARM IN CANADA OFFICE BUILDINGS
IN LAS VEGAS IN ARIZONA.
HE GREW CITRUS AND ALMONDS WELL
ENJOYING LIFE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITH HIS BEAUTIFUL FAMILY.
HE WAS DEDICATED FAMILY MAN HE
SPENDS A PRECIOUS TIME WITH HIS
LOVELY WIFE BETTY JEAN THEY WERE
MARRIED FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
THE AND SHE LOVED HIM DEARLY HE
HAS A WONDERFUL SEND AND A
BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER IN HIS TO
AMAZING GRAND SENS HE WAS A MAN
OF HONOR A MAN OF HIS WORD.
IN A TRUE FRIEND TO ALL QUIRK HE
WAS A FARMER OF THE YEAR -- JUST
RECENTLY AND A PIONEER IN THE
PISTACHIO INDUSTRY AND A LEGEND
REGARDING PISTACHIOS SAVING THE
PISTACHIO INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
HE'LL BE GREATLY MISSED BY ALL
OF THOSE WHO KNEW HIM.
CORKY'S LEGACY LIVES ON WITH HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOREVER BE
GRATEFUL FOR THIS MAN'S
INNOVATIVE INDUSTRY AND IDEAS TO
PROTECT OUR PRECIOUS PISTACHIOS.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
ADJOURNING HIS MEMORY.
PLEASE SEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO
THE ANDERSON FAMILY AS IT TURNED
IN HIS MEMORY [inaudible]
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
CENTERS I ASK YOU TO JON ME IN
A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF THIS
SHIP FRANCIS SAY QUINN.
A BELOVED COMMUNITY LEADER WHO
EXERTED MORAL AUTHORITY.
BUT THE GENTLE TOUCHES SPIRITUAL
HEAD OF CATHOLICS IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION.
THE SHIP QUINN PASSED AWAY AT
NINETY SEVEN YEARS OLD.
HE WAS THE OLDEST LIVING BISHOP
IN THE UNITED STATES AT THE TIME
OF HIS DEATH.
THE SHIP QUINN SERVED FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY TO NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR'S BISHOP OF THE
ROMAN CATHOLIC DIOCESE OF
SACRAMENTO WHICH COVERS FORTY
TWO THOUSAND SQUARE MILES IN
TWENTY COUNTIES.
THE LETTER GROWING FLOCK IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
SEVEN YOU PARISHES TO ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS AND ONE HIGH SCHOOL THAT
OPEN UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP.
HE ENCOURAGE LAY CATHOLICS
ESPECIALLY WOMEN TO TAKE ACTIVE
ROLES IN CHURCH GOVERNANCE IN
MINISTRIES.
HE SUPPORT THE ORDINATION OF
DEACONS TO HELP ALLEVIATE.
THE SHRINKING RANK OF PRIESTS.
BUT IS INFLUENCE REACHED.
BEYOND CATHOLICS PEOPLE OF ALL
WALKS OF LIFE RESPECTED HIS
MORAL LEADERSHIP.
AND RESPONDED TO HIS GENIAL SOFT
SPOKEN MANNER.
AN ADVOCATE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
HE SPOKE AT THE GET OUT AGAINST
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS NUCLEAR
ARMS AND THE US MILITARY
INTERVENTION IN CENTRAL AMERICA.
YOU PUBLICLY CRITICIZE LOCAL
OFFICIALS FOR RAIDS ON HOMELESS
CAMPERS THE LEAD PRAYERS FOR
IMMIGRANTS OUTSIDE THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE.
BUT SHOULD QUINN'S LIFESTYLE AS
A BISHOP WAS MODEST HE DISDAINED
A BIG EXPENSIVE CAR IN FAVOR OF
AN ECONOMICAL FORD ESCORT.
HE EARNED THE NICKNAME BASEMENT
BASEMENT BISHOP FOR SELLING THE
BISHOPS MANSION AND MOVING INTO
A SPARTAN APARTMENT BENEATH THE
CAP.
CATHEDRAL BLESSED SACRAMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN ISSUE WHEN
MOVED TO MERCY MAC MAHONE
TERRACE AND ASSISTED LIVING
RESIDENTS IN SACRAMENTO.
AND UNTIL VERY RECENTLY HE KEPT
THE BUSY SCHEDULE SAYING MASS
FOR RESIDENTS SPEAKING THE
CATHOLIC GROUPS IN VISITING
QUEEN COTTAGES.
A TRANSITIONAL HOUSING CENTER
FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT IS THAT
WAS NAMED IN HIS HONOR.
BISHOP QUINN LIVED A FULL LIFE
AND WAS AN IMPORTANT LEADER OF
OUR SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY AND I
WOULD SAY THERE'S A CALIFORNIA.
AND H WILL BE GREATLY MISSED I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN -- BISHOP.
QUEEN WILL BE LONG REMEMBERED
FOR HIS KINDNESS AND COMPASSION
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN ITS
MEMORY TODAY.
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES I RISE TO A
JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF MERRY YOUNG.
AW WHO PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY
ON FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH MARY WAS
BORN IN DETROIT MICHIGAN ON
DECEMBER EIGHTH -- AND MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SIXTIES
OR WHERE SHE RAISED HER THREE
CHILDREN WITH HER LATE HUSBAND
RON YOUNG.
MERION MERION RON WERE JOYFULLY
MARRIED FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS
UNTIL HIS DEATH IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE SHE WAS WELL
KNOWN FOR HER DECADES OF
TIRELESS VOLUNTEER EFFORTS ON
THE BEHALF OF MANY CANDIDATES
WILL FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SHE WAS HONORED AS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR BY BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY AND THE
CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AS WELL AS NUMEROUS OTHER AWARDS
AND RECOGNITIONS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
DEDICATION TO OUR COMMUNITY HE
CONSIDERED HER VOLUNTEER WORK
FOR HER CAREER AND LIFE'S WORK.
AND SHE WORKED WITH VIGOR FOR
THE CAUSES AND THE PEOPLE SHE
BELIEVED IN.
MERRY WAS PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN CONVEYING TO YOUNG
PEOPLE THE COURAGE OF OUR
FOUNDING FATHERS IN CREATING OUR
NATION AND THE FREEDOMS WE ENJOY.
AS THE FOUNDER AND LONGTIME
MEMBER OF ORANGE COUNTY
REPUBLICAN WOMEN FEDERATED HE
SPONSORED MANY EVENTS ON
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
ENABLE THEMTO VISIT.
OUR STATE CAPITOL I AND OUR
NATION'S CAPITAL TO SEE
DEMOCRACY IN ACTION.
MARION BERRY'S LIFE'S ADVENTURES
AND HAD TRAVELED THE WORLD SHE
INSPIRED EVERYONE WHO IS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO KNOW HER BY
HER LOVING FUN AN EXUBERANT
SPIRIT.
MERRY WAS A WONDERFUL FRIEND
WITH A COMPASSIONATE AND
GENEROUS HEART AND SHE HAD A
SPIRITED SPANKING US THAT
SOMETIMES GOT HER IN A LITTLE
BIT OF TROUBLE.
BUT TO MEET HER -- THE UNIQUE
FIVE FRIENDS THAT WE ALL ENJOYED
SHE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED BY HER
FAMILY AND HER LEGION OF FRANCE
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MARY'S MEMORY THANK YOU.
PLEASE SEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO
THE YOUNG FAMILY AS WE ADJOURN
AND YOUNG'S MEMORY [inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
BETTER PRESIDENT AND FELLOW
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TODAY TO JOIN
ME IN REMEMBERING AND
CELEBRATING THE LIFE.
OF MY FRIEND JOE GIVES LETTER OF
NAPA.
AT SIXTY NINE YEARS OLD JOE WAS
A FOURTH GENERATION NAPA NATIVE
IN ATTENDED NAPA HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WE WAS
ACTIVE IN SPORTS.
AND FUTURE FARMERS OF AMERICA.
JOE RECEIVED AS A DEGREE FROM
NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE AND ALSO
SERVED IN THE ARMY RESERVES.
WHEN HE WAS YOUNG JOE WORK FOR
HIS FATHER AND UNCLE AT THE
FAMILY RANCH AND THEY GOT IS
REAL ESTATE LICENSE?
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HE
STARTED HIS LETTER LANDED
INVESTMENTS AND SOLD
AGRICULTURAL PROPERTY FOR FORTY
ONE YEARS.
ALL THE WHILE DEVELOPING SEVERAL
PROPERTIES IN THE VINEYARDS
ALONG THE WAY.
JOE LOVED HIS ANNUAL FISHING
TRIP WITH FRIENDS IN ALASKA THE
FARTHER IN THE WILD THE HAPPIER
HE WAS.
JOE HAD MANY FRIENDS AND
ENTERTAIN US ALL WITH HIS JOKES
AND GREAT STORIES.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE WHEN
BECAUSE LETTER SIGNED ADDED
GIVES LOT A DAUGHTER IN LAW
STEPHANIE IN HIS GRANDDAUGHTER
RILEY.
HE IS ALSO SURVIVED BY A SON
INJURED HIS LETTER AND DAUGHTER
IN LAW ALICIA AS WELL AS A
SISTER CAROL FINCH.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOINING IN
MEMORY OF JOKER'S LADDER THANK
YOU.
PLEASE EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES AS
WE ARE IN IN HIS MEMORY
[inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AYE
RICE TRADE DURING IN MEMORY OF
KATIE THE MY CONSTITUENT WAS A
RESIDENT OF ROAST MEAT SHE AND
HER HUSBAND FRANK RACE THEIR
FAMILY AND ROAST MEAT AND WE'RE
ALWAYS ACTIVE COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AS A YOUNG GIRL KATIE WAS A
CHEERLEADER CHEERLEADER IN THE
ALL AMERICAN LEAGUE. FOR THE
ROSE MEET REBELS WHICH LED TO
HER INVOLVEMENT LATER IN LIFE.
AS A WIFE AND MOTHER SHE WAS
VERY ACTIVE IN HER CHILDREN'S
SPORTS TEAMS AND BECAME A CARE
COORDINATOR FOR THE REBEL
ORGANIZATION A NONPROFIT THAT
OFFERS FOR BUYING CHEERLEADING.
TO CHILDREN OF ALL AGES SHE
BECAME.
REALLY INVOLVED IN YOUTH SPORTS
AND STAYING ACTIVE SHE LATER
ORGANIZED THE ROAST MEAT ELITE
ETERNALLY GREW FOR ALL GIRLS AND
BOYS WHO PERFORMED AT CITY
EVENTS AND COMPETED IN.
CHEERLEADING COMPETITIONS IN
ADDITION TO HER VOLUNTEER WORK
KATIE WAS ALSO A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
ENJOYED SPENDING TIME IN THE
CLASSROOM WITH ALL THE EARLY.
OUR LEARNERS SINCE THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES SHE SERVED AT
THE CITY EMPLOYEE ALONG WITH HER
DAUGHTERS JENETTE AND BERNADETTE.
MS VICARIO SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND FRANK OF FORTY SEVEN
YEARS HER DAUGHTER TO BED MARIE
G. JANET THE CARDIO BERNADETTE
THE LYNDALL JACKIE WOULD TELL
HER SON FRANK JUNIOR AND HER
FIFTEEN GRANDCHILDREN -- KATIE
VICARIO WILL BE -- SOLELY MISTO
AYE AYE KILEY OUSTED TO ADJOURN
IN HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
PLEASE EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES AS
WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY SENATOR
MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
PRESIDENT -- COLLEAGUES TODAY IS
THE FIFTY FOUR FIFTY FIRST%
ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE ASSASSINATION OF DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
AND I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF YET ANOTHER JURY NOT
JUST DEFERRED BUT A DREAM LOST.
ONCE AGAIN THE GUN VIOLENCE.
ARMENIANS ARE SAID TO THEM.
WHO WAS NO MORE POPULARLY BY HIS
MONIKER NIPSEY HUSSLE? THIRTY
THREE YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN WHO WAS
GUNNED DOWN.
MID DAY WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
PRESENT.
IN FRONT OF HIS VERY OWN
ESTABLISHMENT.
HE WAS THE MANIFESTATION FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM EVEN THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
WERE YOU CAN LIVE AND WORK IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD YOU GROW UP IN.
THE HAVE THAT DREAM GROWING UP
IN SOUTH LA DURING THE TURBULENT
AIR OF THE NINETIES WAS INDEED
VISIONARY.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF AN INVESTMENT
GROUP.
LEADING THE BED TO ACQUIRE SANTA
MONICA'S HISTORIC VICEROY HOTEL.
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMINATION GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THE FACT THAT HE
REPRESENTS A NEW GENERATION OF
ENTERTAINER.
TURNED ACTIVIST TURNED
ENTREPRENEUR.
WHAT WAS UNIQUE ABOUT THIS YOUNG
MAN?
WITH THAT HE ENCOMPASSED ALL
THREE SPACES SIMULTANEOUSLY.
HE WAS AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN
LOCAL PROTESTS AND MEETINGS.
AROUND POLICE BRUTALITY GUN
VIOLENCE.
HE NOT MERELY PURCHASE
FRANCHISES BUT HE BECAME.
AT INCUBATED NEW CONCEPTS OF
ENTERPRISE.
HE OPENED A COWORKING SPACE IN
STEM CENTER CALLED VECTOR.
NINETY IN SOUTH LA.
HE PIONEERED INNOVATIVE MEASURES
IN MARKETING AND SELF PROMOTION.
HE OPENED THE FIRST SMART STORE
FOR HIS OWN FRANCHISE BRAND IN
SOUTH LA WE'RE VISITORS USE A
OUT TO ENHANCE THEIR SHOPPING
EXPERIENCE.
HE WITH THE EARLY SUPPORTER OF
THE NEW ART AND CULTURE PROJECT
ALONG THE CRINGE RECORDER.
AT THE YOUNG AGE OF THIRTY THREE
HE HAD A TEN YEAR HISTORY THE
MUSIC INDUSTRY.
AT THIS CURRENT ALBUM PREMIERED
TO CRITICAL ACCLAIM.
ON NUMBER FOUR AT NUMBER FOUR ON
THE BILLBOARD CHART.
HE AND HIS FAMILY WERE RECENTLY
FEATURED.
ENOUGH SPREAD IN GENTLEMAN'S
QUARTERLY MAGAZINE.
THAT INCLUDED ARTISTICALLY FOR
DINING PHOTOS TAKEN IN THE HEART
OF MY BELOVED SOUTH LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY.
THOSE IMAGES REPRESENT WHAT HE
BELIEVED WHAT I BELIEVE IS
INDEED POSSIBLE.
I ROLES ON THIS FLOOR JUST
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO TO TALK ABOUT
THE TRAUMA A COMMUNITY WAS
EXPERIENCING AS A RESULT.
OF THE DEATH.
BY VIOLENT GUN SHOP OF THE YOUNG
STUDENT AT USC.
AND ONCE AGAIN MY COMMUNITY OF
SOUTH LOS ANGELES IS
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA.
BASED ON THE LOSS OF A BRAND NEW
YOUNG ICON WHEN WE USE THE TERM
ICON WE TYPICALLY ARE REFERRING
TO SOMEONE.
WITH FAR MORE ADVANCED IN AGE
BUT THE THIRTY THREE YEAR OLD
WAS THE I CON.
IN THE INDUSTRY AND IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THE AMAZING LA TIMES ARTICLE
ABOUT TWO WEEKS BEFORE HIS
UNTIMELY DEATH.
THE TALKED ABOUT THIS NEW COAL
WORKING IN SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY LAB IN SOUTH LA THAT
HE OPENED.
AND HE SHARED THE FACT THAT AS A
YOUNG MAN.
MUSIC AND TECHNOLOGY OR HIS
DREAMS HIS PASSION AND BECAUSE
OF A LACK OF RESOURCES HE
LEARNED HOW TO BUILD A PC
HIMSELF.
OUT OF PARTS FOUND.
SO HE COULD RECORD HIS OWN MUSIC.
HE WAS THE INNOVATOR IN THE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE HE DIDN'T SIGN
WITH A LABEL UNTIL THIS VERY
LAST RECENT ALBUM AFTER TEN
YEARS IN THE INDUSTRY.
HE CREATED MODELS BY WHICH HE
COULD OWN HIS OWN IMAGE.
OWN HIS OWN MUSIC AND SELL IT BY
CUTTING OUT ALL THE VARIOUS
MIDDLE MAN.
THAT ENCOMPASS THAT SPACE.
AND SO I'M HOPING THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE AND OLD PEOPLE LIKE ME
ACROSS THE STATE WON'T LOSE THE
DREAM [inaudible]
OF BUYING PROPERTY TRULY OWNING
AND ENVISIONING SMALL BUSINESSES
IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS IN WHICH WE
GREW UP IN.
REGARDLESS OF WHEN SOCIAL
ECONOMIC STATUS I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TODAY BUT I ASKED
THAT WE ALL A JUROR IN MEMORY.
OF THE YOUNG MAN OF ERITREAN AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN DESCENT.
BY THE NAME OF ARMENIA.
A SECOND -- ALSO KNOWN AS NIPSEY
HUSSLE THANK YOU.
PLEASE EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES ON
IS CREDIBLE LOSS AS WE ADJOURN
IN ITS MEMORY SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES IN AND TURNING.
AND THE MEMORY OF ARMY AND A
YOUNG MAN WHO ARE PAPS DIDN'T
CROSS DIRECTLY BUT INDIRECTLY I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT HIS
TECH CENTER.
LAST JULY MEETING WITH FORMER
SPEAKER AND NOW CONGRESSWOMAN
KAREN BASS AND I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
AT THE CONVERGENCE OF THIS
WAREHOUSE THAT IT EXISTED JUST
BLOCKS AWAY FROM MY FATHER OWNED
A RECORD SHOP AS A KID GROWING
UP.
AND JUST KNOWING OBJECTS TRUCKS
AND ALL KIND OF UNDESIRABLE
STUFF THAT HAPPENED AROUND THERE
AND TO WALK INTO THIS BUILDING
THAT'D BEEN TOLD HE TRANSFORMED.
TO SEE YOUNG FOLKS WORKING AT
COMPUTERS AND DESIGN CENTERS AND
LONG BEFORE IT EVER LISTEN TO
ANY OF HIS MUSIC.
WE KNEWABOUT HIS CONTRIBUTIONS
IN THE COMMUNITY WORKING WITH
BASKETBALL GREATS LIKE WHAT BOB
RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
AND REPAVING BASKETBALL COURTS
IMPURE BEAUTIFYING PARKS ONE
WHICH WAS RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER FROM WHERE I LIVE IN
RALEIGH PARK WHERE THEY RE DID
THE BASKETBALL COURT.
KNOWING HIS IMPACT AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM US SENATE SENT
INVESTING IN SLOT SYMBOL OF ART.
A A STREET THAT MANY AT GIVEN UP
ON OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
BECAUSE OF MANY OF THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS DIDN'T SEE.
THE BEAUTIFICATION BUT IT
INDIVIDUAL WHO TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
MANY OF THE AWS THAT WE HAVE
CREATED BOTH HERE IN WASHINGTON
BY CHRIS A TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
IN INVESTING IN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS THESE TAX BREAKS WOULD
ALLOW HIM TO STRETCHES DOLLARS
FAR FARTHER THAN GOING.
TO BEVERLY HILLS OR WEST LA
BEING SMART ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
WITH THE METRO LINE COMING DOWN
CURRENT JOB ALL OF OUR LESS THAN
A QUARTER MILE FROM THE STORE.
IT WOULD HAVE YEAH INCREASE FOOT
TRAFFIC FOR HIS STORE.
JUST THIS JANUARY AFTER I
COMPLETED THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
PARADE DOWN CURRENT TROUBLE OF
ART I SAW A FRIEND OF MINE
STANDING.
ON THE CORNER WITH THIS
BEAUTIFUL SWEAT SHIRT EMBLAZONED
WITH CRUNCH ON IT.
AND I YELLED FROM THE CARS TO
WORRY TO GET THAT.
AND SHE SAID MARATHON.
I SAYS MARATHON HE SAYS YES
ONSLAUGHTS SYMBOL OF ART.
AND I IMMEDIATELY WENT OVER
THERE NOT KNOWING THAT IT WAS.
NIPSEY HUSSLE STORE AND I WAS
BLOWN AWAY ONCE I WALKED IN
THERE JUST TO SEE.
THIS BEAUTIFUL DISPLAY I HAD HIS
INVESTMENT IN HIS COMMUNITY.
ADD A INVESTMENT OF A SHOPPING
CENTER THAT AT LONG BEEN
DILAPIDATED.
AND HE HAD BEAUTIFIED IT BUT HE
WAS JUST IN THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT HE WANTED TO DO THERE HE
WAS.
WORKING ON PLANS NOT ONLY.
TO REDEVELOP THE CONCERT -- THE
COMMERCIAL LEVEL OF IT BUT ALSO
PUT FORTY TWO HUNDRED HOUSING
UNITS ON THAT PROPERTY ALONG
SLAWSON TO HELP WITH THIS
HOMELESS CRISIS HELP WITH THE
AFFORDABILITY OF A MAKING ALL
HOMES AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO.
DIDN'T HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE THIS
YOUNG MAN WAS COMMITTED AND
DESPITE MANY TIMES WE'LL TALK
ABOUT A FORMER GANG MEMBER HE
STAYED CONNECTED WITH THAT
COMMUNITY BECAUSE HE UNDERSTOOD.
HOW HE BENEFITTED FROM THAT
STREET EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL EXPERIENCE ANY
TOOK THE BEST A WHAT HE KNEW
LEARNED FROM PEOPLE LIKE JAY Z.
AND SEAN PUFFY COMBS AM?
AND A DOCTOR DRAY INSTEAD I WANT
TO AND REINVEST IN MY COMMUNITY.
THIS YOUNG MAN SOLD A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MIX TAPES.
ON OUR ON THE STREET JZ BOUGHT A
HUNDRED OF THEM AT A HUNDRED
DOLLARS APIECE.
AT A HUNDRED DOLLARS A PIECE HE
WAS MAKING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS A MONTH HE COULD LIVE
ANYWHERE IN LAS SANDERS ANYWHERE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT HE CHOSE TO
STAY.
IN THE COMMUNITY AND WORK WITH.
HIS FRIENDS AND THOSE WHO WERE
FAR.
LESS -- BOSTON HE HE SAID THE
HIGHEST HUMAN ACT IS TO INSPIRE.
WE MUST ALL AGREE HE INSPIRED
MANY MANY YOUNG FOLKS AS WELL AS
OLD FOLKS.
AS WELL.
I INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS TO WAS
TAKEN AWAY FAR TOO SOON.
AND I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH THIS
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MIGHT BE
UNFAMILIAR WITH HIS.
MUSIC.
LIFE IS A MARATHON.
BUT BEFORE WE TAKE THE VICTORY
LAP.
WE SHOULD ALL RAISE OUR RIGHT
HAND TO GOD.
AND DOUBLE UP ON OUR COMMITMENT
IN GUN VIOLENCE BECAUSE THE LAST
TIME I CHECKED.
A BULLETIN GOT NO NAME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR.
AS WE MOURN THIS -- TRAGEDY --
WE WILL ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
THAT A PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO A GERMAN MEMORY OF JACOB OR
MOVES US AND JACOB SNYDER.
BOTH BOYS ONLY SEVENTEEN YEARS
OLD WERE TRAGICALLY KILLED ON
MONDAY.
WHILE RESCUING A DOG FROM MAKE
YOUR GAUGING CAN NOW.
JACOB OR MOSES AND JACOB SNYDER
WERE BOTH STUDENTS ADDICTS IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY LEAVE BEHIND MANY FRIENDS
AND FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY IS HEARTBROKEN
THAT THESE TWO YOUNG LIVES WERE
CUT SHORT AND I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME IN A JOURNEYING IN THEIR
MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND PLEASE
SEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY OF THESE YOUNG MEN.
AS WE ADJOURN IN THEIR MEMORY.
THING OVER THERE AND TURN IN
MEMORIES.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR WALK THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
MADE AND WE'LL RECONVENE RIGHT
BACK HERE.
NEXT MONDAY AT TWO PM MEMBERS
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
WE ARE ADJOURNED [inaudible]
OKAY.
MEMBERS WE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL.
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
AND WE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY
AT TWO PM